Professor David Blight:
We're going to elect,
that is re-elect,
Lincoln in a moment,
the election of 1864 being one
of the, without a question,
crucial turning points in the
war,
in a war that was so political.
But spare the poets.
I want to begin by placing you
somewhere.
The ending of the Civil War,
of course, was for thousands
upon thousands,
really millions of Americans,
a confrontation with death on a
scale they'd never known,
never experienced,
and frankly never have again.
There's a marvelous new book on
this, two new books on this,
one in particular by Drew
Faust,
whom you've read already,
a book called The Republic
of Suffering,
which I recommend to
you--it just came out a couple
of months ago--which is all
about the death culture that the
Civil War bred.
Our greatest death poet was
Whitman.
This is risky.
I'm going to actually recite a
little piece,
little bits,
of what could be Whitman's
greatest poem,
at least it in my view.
But what do I know?
I'm not a literary scholar.
But there are ways in Whitman's
"When Lilacs Last in the
Dooryard Bloom'd" that he is
actually anticipating what's
going to happen,
with time, to the problem of
how Americans will remember this
ghastly bloodletting they've
just experienced.
It's, of course,
the poem about Lincoln's death.
Whitman really had a thing
about Lincoln,
as you may know.
He wrote possibly the only poem
that ever rhymed in his
magnificent collection,
"O Captain!
My Captain," in relation to
Lincoln's death.
But "Lilacs" is a masterpiece.
It's the poem he wrote to try
to imagine the funeral train of
Abraham Lincoln,
the train that took some twenty
days;
three coffins,
because two got damaged.
It stopped in,
I forget now,
sixteen, seventeen different
cities on this incredible tour
all over New England and then
all across the North and the
Midwest and finally to his
burial in Springfield,
Illinois.
And what Whitman really wrote
here was a kind of a
calming--it's written in a mood
of a kind a calming,
depoliticized,
contemplation on what Whitman
called "the fathomless,
sure-enwinding arms of
cool-enfolding death."
But it's very much directly
about Lincoln's death.
And Whitman imagines a songbird;
calls it a warbling.
And he says he hears this
warbling singing a solitary
song, his words,
"of the bleeding throat,
Death's outlet song of life,
(for well dear brother)"--he's
speaking to the bird now--"(for
well dear brother I know,
If thou wast not granted to
sing thou wouldst surely die.)"
And he's trying to use the
bird--go read this poem,
read it three,
four, and five times--he's
trying to use the warbling,
the song sparrow,
as a metaphor for all of
America.
"How shall I warble?"
Here he gives voice to the bird.
He even writes lyrics for the
bird.
"How shall I warble myself for
the dead one that I loved?"
It's like an offering.
Whitman picks a sprig of lilac,
he says, and places Abraham
Lincoln's funeral train in the
setting of what he calls "ever
returning spring across the vast
landscape of America,
from east to the prairie."
It was April,
like now, a little later;
lilacs were in bloom by late in
the month.
And then comes this magnificent
verse.
"Over the breast of spring,
the land, amidst cities,
Amid lanes and through old
woods,
where lately the violets peep'd
from the ground,
spotting the grey debris,
Amid the grass in the fields
each side of the lanes,
passing the endless grass,
Passing the yellow-spear'd
wheat, every grain from its
shroud in the dark brown fields
uprisen,
Passing the apple-tree blows of
white and pink in the orchards,
Carrying a corpse to where it
shall rest in the grave,
Night and day journeys a
coffin."
And then he says the bird must
sing its "carol of death."
And the poet tries to give
words to the music,
yet one senses that even
Whitman,
with all his powers,
could not match the little
warbling's power,
to deliver what he calls "that
powerful psalm in the night."
This is a poem of grief for the
whole country.
He's trying to capture the
meaning of death,
all that death,
caused in the Civil War,
if it's possible.
But he gives the job to a tiny
little bird.
Whitman himself,
he says, is left with
"visions," his words,
"of battle-corpses" and "the
debris of all the slain soldiers
of the war," in his head.
The funeral train passes by all
the images the poet can muster
and then he's just left to say,
his words: "The living remained
and suffered."
Now I'll return to Whitman.
It's one way to get a handle,
if it is a handle,
on what Americans were coping
with in 1865,
the level and scale of
sacrifice that they had
experienced.
And of course Lincoln's
assassination came two,
three days after Robert E.
Lee's surrender at Appomattox.
More on that in a minute.
But back up with me,
back up with me into that last
year of the war.
It was still possible for the
South to win its version of a
victory as late as I'd say
August of 1864;
I suppose you could even say
September, but after the fall of
Atlanta it wasn't likely.
But now quickly,
that election of '64 was one of
the most important in our
history.
We don't pay a lot of attention
to it because we kind of speed
by it or around it and we almost
ignore it sometimes--oh it's
another election,
let's get on with the Civil War.
Across the North there was
tremendous war weariness that
summer.
I mentioned already,
65 -- 66,0000 casualties in
Grant's Army alone in Virginia
in two and a half months.
There was great bitterness
against the draft that summer.
Now, in the end only about six,
seven percent of all Union
soldiers will actually be
draftees, but there was
tremendous resentment against
it.
In the North there were the
Peace Democrats;
or sometimes that's what they
were called.
Sometimes they were called
Copperheads, named for the
snake.
Copperheads usually though were
those people who somehow were
deemed truly disloyal to the
Union and actually were engaging
in machinations and conspiracies
to overthrow the Union.
That's always been an open
question.
There was an effort within the
Republican Party as early as May
and June of '64 to dump Lincoln
in place of either Salmon Chase,
a member of Lincoln's cabinet,
his Attorney General--and read
Doris Kearns Goodwin's Team
of Rivals if you want to
know just how much Chase was
scheming to dump Lincoln,
as his own Attorney General.
Chase may have had the most
beautiful daughter in
Washington, Kate Chase,
but he had no style.
And then there was an effort to
dump Lincoln in favor of the
candidate John C.
Fremont, the same Fremont who
had run in 1856 as the
Republican presidential
candidate.
And Lincoln was himself all but
convinced, by July and early
August of '64,
that he probably wouldn't win
re-election;
what to do in the meantime?
The Democratic Party nominated
George B.
McClellan, the former general,
commanding General of the Army
of the Potomac.
That Democratic Party in the
midst of the Civil War was a
confusing lot,
and one might even say a
confused lot.
Some of them truly wanted to
sue for a negotiated peace,
but they would always say they
wanted a negotiated peace of the
South that would still restore
the Union.
And, of course,
that was never acceptable to
Jefferson Davis and the
Confederate government.
Many of them were quite
explicitly for a negotiated
peace that would not result in
emancipation.
They wanted to turn
emancipation around.
They wanted a Union without
emancipation;
that is exactly what McClellan
wanted.
There was a deeply white
supremacist strain in much of
the northern Democratic Party
and they put up a formidable
challenge to wartime president,
in the midst of Civil War.
They painted Lincoln and the
Republicans as what they
constantly called
miscegenationist;
they used the term all the time.
The Republicans were going to
make whites and blacks marry
each other.
They called Abraham Lincoln,
in this campaign,
"Abe the widow maker."
They were already waving the
bloody shirt that would become
so ubiquitous in the wake of the
war, blaming Lincoln for all the
death.
They also referred to him as
"Abe the nigger lover."
And the Democratic papers
produced cartoons,
famous cartoons--I wish I had
an example of one today--of what
they called miscegenation balls;
these were dances and balls
where whites and blacks all came
together, kissed,
made love and mixed the races.
What Lincoln desperately needed
was battlefield success to alter
Northern war morale;
and of course they got that.
They got it with the fall of
Mobile Harbor in the first and
second week of August--Admiral
David Farragut,
in the largest naval engagement
of the war, took Mobile,
the last major southern
seaport,
to come into Union hands--and
then especially with the fall of
Atlanta, on the 3^(rd) of
September '64.
And then in the month of
September further victories by
Philip Sheridan's cavalry in the
Shenandoah Valley,
driving Confederate armies
basically out of the Shenandoah
Valley, made it now possible to
say that the war was on a course
of Union victory,
that the Confederacy was in a
state of near collapse.
And when the election came the
votes were there.
Lincoln won fifty-five percent
of the total popular vote.
Forty-five percent of the
electorate in the northern
states did not vote for Lincoln
and in effect,
therefore, were not voting for
emancipation.
Keep that in mind when we start
discussing Reconstruction.
Eighteen of the Free states
made it possible for soldiers to
vote at the front;
only two did not,
and even those let soldiers
vote by absentee.
It is the first time in world
history, so far as we know,
that a republic in the
midst--there weren't that many
republics to speak of,
of course--but the first time
in the course of a civil war
that a republic held a general
election and pulled it off.
Most importantly,
Lincoln won an extraordinary
seventy-eight percent of the
soldier vote,
of all those hundreds of
thousands in the Army and Navy,
and they voted in droves.
It was, that election,
a referendum on the war,
and it was a referendum on its
purpose, and it was a
referendum, therefore,
on emancipation.
One of the most extraordinary
events that happened in that
election season was in the third
week of August of '64,
Lincoln invited--this time
invited--Frederick Douglass to
come to the White House.
They had met the year before in
August, in '63,
but that was at Douglass's own
prodding.
In '63 Douglass had gone to the
White House to complain about
unequal pay and brutal
discriminations against black
troops in the Union armies,
and he got an audience,
at least for awhile,
with Lincoln--the first time
they met,
the beginnings of a remarkable
relationship.
But in '64 Lincoln invites
Douglass--and Douglass didn't
know what he was going to be
asked to do.
And they sat down for about
forty-five minutes,
eye to eye, and Abraham Lincoln
asked Frederick Douglass to lead
a campaign to funnel as many
slaves out of the upper south
into some kind of security in
the North,
before election day in
November, because he feared he
would not be re-elected and he
wanted as many slaves as
possible to be secure within
Union lines and somehow legally
free under the proclamation,
before McClellan won the
election.
Now frankly,
Douglass was stunned.
Here was Abe Lincoln asking him
to be John Brown,
sort of.
He could hardly believe it,
and he left there with a whole
new kind of conception of
Lincoln,
frankly--not entirely new,
he was already working on that.
But he went back home to
Rochester, New York and he
organized about fifteen or
sixteen agents,
by letter and telegram,
in late August and the first
week of September,
all over the North.
He didn't have a clue how he
was really going to do this,
or how much the army was really
going to help him,
but he started calling all his
old friends in the abolition
movement, and a lot of the
people who'd been recruiting
black troops,
and said, "Help me,
we're gonna funnel slaves out
of the South.
I don't know how but help me."
And then came the fall of
Atlanta, a couple of Sheridan's
victories in the Shenandoah,
and the whole scheme was called
off.
But it's a measure of Lincoln's
own sense of reality,
that he was about to lose.
All right, the war ended,
of course, in great part with
the surrender at Appomattox,
and then with the surrender of
Joseph Johnston to Sherman in a
farmhouse in central North
Carolina,
about ten days later--what is
it, April 21,
I believe?
Let me discuss that briefly.
It's an extremely important
moment and event,
and the terms of that surrender
are extremely important for
what's to come.
In a war that had become so
political, so much about morale,
so much about public opinion,
so much about the will of two
peoples to see it through.
The surrender terms were
actually almost utterly
apolitical.
I had a couple of photos up
here.
I don't know if you can see
this very well.
This is one of many photographs
that Mathew Brady and his troop
of photographers took of
Richmond,
after it fell April 5,1865,
as so many journalists now
started saying the United States
was finally an old country
because it had ruins.
Isn't that great?
You need some ruins to have a
history.
Well, Richmond fell 5^(th) of
April of '65,
and Lee's army did escape.
He was experiencing tremendous
desertion.
He escaped westward.
The goal he had,
so far as we know,
was to reach the Blue Ridge
Mountains and maybe even get
south into North Carolina,
maybe hook up with Johnston's
army that was retreating in
front of Sherman up into North
Carolina,
maybe somehow connect the two
remaining Confederate armies,
and carry on the war,
if they could.
Lee really didn't ever,
ever want to give up.
But he had to.
He was cut off.
There was an emerging lethal
mixture now, of no supplies,
desertion, and the almost
unfathomable oversupply of the
Union forces.
He was grossly outnumbered and
finally he had to send a note,
after this last little battle
they actually fought,
on the 11^(th) of April,
where eighteen men were killed.
And there's a little cemetery
at Appomattox today where you
can see the gravestones of those
eighteen men.
It's one of the most moving
little cemeteries I've ever
seen.
They're the last to die in a
totally futile battle.
The terms of the surrender were
essentially this--and,
by the way, they were Lincoln's
direct orders.
That's a parole slip.
It's a photocopy of exactly
what they looked like.
The Union Army took printing
presses out to Appomattox
Courthouse, which was this
little town,
and they set it up in a tavern
and they pumped out these parole
slips, about 25 to 30,000 of
them in forty-eight hours.
The Confederate soldiers were
given these paroles.
They were allowed to keep their
side arms, they had to surrender
their rifles,
they were allowed to keep
horses if they had them,
and in essence they were simply
told go home.
Nobody, except technically Lee
himself, was taken into custody.
But Lee's custody was simply
the right to ride his horse back
to Richmond, if he chose,
or wherever he wanted to go,
and he was technically put
under house arrest--not allowed
to leave his house for some
period of time--but never
charged with anything.
Jefferson Davis will--more on
that later.
Alexander H.
Stephens, the vice-president,
will technically be charged,
although never tried.
Davis will be charged but never
tried.
No one, except the commandant
of Andersonville Prison,
one Captain Wirz,
a Swiss born immigrant who
commanded Andersonville,
the worst of the South's
prisons, he was the only person
accused of treason and war
crimes and executed as a result
of this war.
Now Lee and Grant,
of course, met--and Ken Burns
milks this for all it's worth,
so I'm going to let you feel it
from him--they met at the McLean
House at Appomattox.
Go there someday.
It still looks almost exactly
as it looked in 1865.
Grant and Lee barely remembered
one another.
They knew each other now--and
altogether extraordinarily
well--from fighting each other
for so long.
They sat down in the parlor of
this house and Grant gave Lee
the terms.
Lee dressed up in his finest
golden sash.
He wore a sword.
He fully expected this to be a
traditional eighteenth or
nineteenth century surrender.
He was going to give his sword
and all that nonsense,
but Grant just said,
"I don't want your sword,
go home."
Now it's also true that when
they finally cut Lee's army off,
and Lee had to send that note
and say,
"Please meet me to consider
surrender terms," the news just
zoomed around the Union army and
Union soldiers just stated going
crazy,
celebrating,
screaming, shooting off guns,
riding on their horses all over
the place,
"The war's over,
the war's over,
God damn rebels have
surrendered."
And Grant put out an order all
through his army that there
would be no celebrations.
It was Grant already
understanding that the surrender
had to be political too,
and that there would be
tremendous untold bitterness to
deal with in the wake of this
war.
Grant, as a general,
had no idea what politically
would come.
He wasn't involved yet in
reconstruction plans at all.
But it also was a kind of
statement, of course,
of honor among soldiers.
To the South,
you can rest assured,
the day they heard about
Appomattox was the way it was
for most Northerners about the
day they heard of Lincoln's
assassination.
It is all over diaries,
all over literature.
It sometimes is just called
"the surrender," "the day we
heard."
There's so many statements of
it, throughout Southern letters
and diaries, as I've said.
I'll just read a couple,
just briefly,
and then one from a Northerner,
to show you what this moment
means on both sides and how
difficult reconstruction is
going to be-- just look at their
diaries.
Remember Kate Stone?
I read from her diary before,
a Louisiana planter woman who
fled over to Texas and lost most
of her slaves.
She writes into her diary.
"April 28, '65:
All are fearfully depressed,"
she reports.
"I cannot bear to hear them
talk of defeat."
She still hoped that
Confederate armies might rally
and fight, as she puts it,
"to be free or die."
Easy for her to say.
On May 15 she opened a journal
entry with this definition,
that I may have read before,
where the first words are
"conquered, submission,
subjugation," she says,
"are the words in my heart."
And then when she hears that
John Wilkes Booth has shot
Lincoln, she rejoiced in
Lincoln's death and honored,
at least in her diary,
John Wilkes Booth for,
quote, "ridding the world of a
tyrant.
We are glad he is not alive to
rejoice in our humiliation and
insult us with his jokes."
There are thousands of those
expressions in Southern letters
and diaries.
That spring and summer an
estimated 8 to 10,000
ex-Confederates,
many of them former officers,
would flee the country.
They ended up going to Brazil,
England, other parts of Europe,
Mexico, Canada,
and a few even went as far away
as Japan, for fear--I mean,
Jubal Early,
that conniving old rat--more on
him later--he ran to Mexico.
He was certain they were all
going to be executed,
at least the officer corps of
Lee's army--none of them were.
And let me read you a diary
entry from a Northern woman,
a great diarist.
Her diary's hardly known,
but man, her diary is almost
equal to Mary Chestnut.
I first encountered it in a
manuscript at the American
Antiquarian Society in
Worchester.
Her name was Caroline Barrett
White.
She kept a diary for years,
decades, and her war-years
diary is extraordinary.
This is her April 10,1865 entry.
"Hurrah, hurrah,
sound the loud timbale over
Egypt's dark sea.
Early this morning our ears
were greeted with the sound of
bells ringing a joyous peal.
General Lee had surrendered
with his whole army to General
Grant!"
She's got exclamation marks all
over the place.
"Surely this is the Lord's
doing, and it is marvelous in
our eyes."
And she goes on and on and on,
all kinds of biblical cadences
to talk about the sense of
jubilation she sees in the
streets of her Massachusetts
town.
And then five days later,
April 15, comes this entry,
and it's the longest entry in
her diary,
several pages,
and all around the outside of
the pages she blackened the
edges.
She writes, "The darkest day I
ever remember.
This morning the sun rose upon
a nation jubilant with victory,
but it sets upon one plunged
into deepest sorrow."
Her longest of all diary
entries she talked about the
shocking intelligence of
Lincoln's murder,
and then says,
"Where will treason ever end?
The rapidity with which events
crowd upon one another now is
perfectly bewildering."
Indeed it was.
Now, as was so often the case
in this war though,
Abraham Lincoln left one of the
best descriptions of what the
war had been about.
In the greatest speech ever
delivered by an American
president--I would venture that;
we could get up a debate on
that I'm sure.
But what are you going to put
up against the Second Inaugural
for an economy of language and a
music of words and an honesty of
meaning?
Read the Second Inaugural;
it only takes about three
minutes.
He's been re-elected.
This is March '65.
The war is almost over;
not there yet.
What does he say in that speech?
What had it been about?
How does he explain all the
death?
He doesn't find that easy.
But in the second paragraph,
and the third paragraph,
came a few phrases that we've
been trying to answer through
interpretation in our 65 to
70,000 books on the Civil War,
more than one a day that we've
written ever since.
He's thinking back to his First
Inaugural and he says,
"Both parties deprecated war,
but one of them would make war
rather than let the nation
survive, and the other would
accept war rather than let it
perish."
That's his interpretation;
of course, he's going to get
vast disagreement on that from
Southerners.
And then the famous phrase,
"And the war came."
There are more titles of books
on the Civil War taken from this
speech than anything else ever
done.
When in doubt,
people just go to Lincoln's
Second Inaugural and find some
little phrase,
if they can find three words
somebody else hasn't used
before, and it becomes the title
of their book.
Kenneth Stamp used And the
War Came,
a book on secession.
Jim McPherson has a new book of
essays out, it's called
Mighty Scourge of War;
it comes out of here.
Stephen Oates' biography of
Abraham Lincoln,
Malice Toward None.
I mean, it's just endless.
But then in that next
paragraph, "One-eighth of the
whole population were colored
slaves."
Three weeks ago when Barack
Obama used the word "slave,"
"slavery," or "slaves,"
seven times in that remarkable
speech, it's remarkable because
it's been altogether rare that
presidents or presidential
candidates have ever mouthed the
word "slave" in American
political rhetoric.
But Lincoln did.
"One-eighth of the whole
population were colored slaves,
not distributed generally over
the Union, but localized in the
southern part."
No kidding.
And here it is.
"These slaves constituted a
peculiar and powerful interest."
Whoa.
"All knew," says Lincoln,
"that this interest was somehow
the cause of the war."
Somehow; that's the greatest
somehow in American letters.
We've been trying to explain
the somehow ever since,
and we never can quite pin it
down.
And before that paragraph's
over you'd been treated to some
of the most beautiful rhetoric
ever written,
at least by an American
president.
He says that everybody wished
for a result less fundamental
and astounding.
We don't want all this
revolution, but that's what we
got.
And then comes that line,
"for every drop of blood shed
by the lash, it shall be paid by
the sword."
You can't hear it or read it
and not know what the war had
been about.
Now, we're going to deal in the
next several lectures about the
extended question of results of
this war, the consequences,
short and long-term.
And there are many things we
can put on that list,
to say the least.
And let me just give you a
short list to begin with,
and we're going to come back to
so much of this.
A quick list.
Just keep it handy.
And some of them are actually
signaled in that Second
Inaugural.
I mean, one is that secession
was killed, almost forever.
Now and then you hear about the
Upper Peninsula of Michigan
wanting to secede or something;
Texas once in awhile gets back
on its heels and says "don't
mess with Texas" and says
they're going to secede,
and some parts of the country
say "go ahead."
There's a fundamental change in
the nature of American
nationalism and the
centralization of government
that will come out of this war.
Eleven of the first twelve
amendments to the U.S.
Constitution had been written
to limit national power.
This is just fundamental.
It's one of Lincoln's less
fundamental and astounding
results.
Six of the next seven
constitutional amendments will
be directly to increase federal
power;
more on that as we do
Reconstruction.
Power itself will shift from
south to north,
at least for awhile,
in American political culture.
Nativism will be put on the
run, at least for awhile,
quite awhile.
The old Nativist Party and all
that nativism of antebellum
America, what are you going to
do with all that xenophobic
nativism in the wake of a war
where one of every four Union
soldiers was foreign born?
And now they're U.S.
citizens claiming pensions on
the U.S.
Government for saving the
Union;
thank you very much.
What Nativist party is going to
get any traction with Union
veterans in the 1870s?
None.
The Labor Movement and the
Women's Rights Movements,
on the other hand,
are going to be crippled--not
ruined,
but crippled--by the Civil War,
by the authoritarianism of war,
all its centralization.
And emancipation,
of course, ushered into
national life all sorts of new
challenges,
new ideas, new meanings,
and this most difficult
American idea of all,
racial equality.
God, what are you going to do
with that now?
It's been taken out of
its--it's been unshucked from
its shell, by war.
Oh, there'll be a thousand
meanings, and we'll come back to
six or seven of them.
Now, I want to introduce
Reconstruction plans here in
just one moment,
but at this particular moment
in time,
of all the possible meanings
people had taken from this
war--and of course they're very
different meanings if you're one
of those white Georgians who had
to face Sherman's Army,
of if you're Kate Stone out in
Texas, or if you're a widow of
your husband and four of your
sons who've died in the war.
I mean, there are many,
many, many different individual
stories.
But think back to what Lincoln
had just said in the Second
Inaugural about what the war had
been about,
and this chastening that it had
brought the country.
One of the most remarkable
documents left from this massive
documentation of this war,
and of emancipation,
is this letter.
Perhaps you've seen it before,
it's getting reprinted now and
then.
It's a letter written by a
former slave whose name was
Jordan Anderson.
How many of you've read Jordan
Anderson's letter before?
Good, the grad students have,
better have,
yes.
Well, this is in the summer of
'65.
What had the war meant?
Jordan Anderson had been a
slave in Tennessee.
He's living in Ohio now.
The war's over.
He gets a letter from his old
master, whose name was Colonel
P.H.
Anderson.
And Jordan's living in Dayton,
Ohio.
And he writes back,
to Colonel Anderson.
He says, "Thank you very much
for your letter."
Anderson wants him to come back.
"Dear Sir, I got your letter,
and was glad to find you had
not forgotten old Jordan,
and that you wanted me to come
back and live with you again,
promising to do better for me
than anybody else can.
I have often felt uneasy about
you.
I thought the Yankees would've
hung you long before this for
harboring Rebs they found at
your house.
I suppose they never heard
about you going to Colonel
Martin's to kill the Union
soldier that was left by his
company in their stable.
Although you shot at me twice
before I left you,
I did not want to hear of your
being hurt, and am glad you are
still living.
It would do me good to go back
to the dear old home again,
see Miss Mary and Miss Martha
and Allan and Esther and Green
and Lee.
Give my love to them all,
and tell them I hope we will
meet in a better world,
if not in this.
I would've gone back to see you
all when I was working in the
Nashville Hospital,
but one of the neighbors told
me Henry intended to shoot me,
if he ever got a chance.
I want to know particularly
what the good chance is you
proposed to give me.
I'm doing tolerably well here.
I get $25.00 a month with
victuals and clothing,
have a comfortable home for
Mandy"--that's his wife.
"The folks here call her Mrs.
Anderson, and the children,
Millie Jane and Grundy,
go to school and are learning.
The teacher says Grundy has a
head to be a preacher.
They go to Sunday school,
and Mandy and me attend church
regularly.
We are kindly treated.
Sometimes we overhear others
saying, 'Them colored people
were slaves down in Tennessee.'
The children feel hurt when
they hear such remarks,
but I will tell them it was no
disgrace in Tennessee to belong
to Colonel Anderson.
Many darkies would have been
proud, as I used to was,
to call you 'Master.'
Now, if you will write and say
what wages you will give me,
I will be better able to decide
whether it would be to my
advantage to move back again.
As to my freedom,
which you say I can have,
there's nothing to be gained on
that score as I got my Free
Papers in 1864 from the Provost
Marshal General of the
Department of Nashville.
Mandy says she would be afraid
to go back without some proof
that you are sincerely disposed
to treat us justly,
and we have concluded to test
your sincerity by asking you to
send us our wages for the time
we served you.
This will make us forget,
and forgive old scores,
and rely on your justice,
and friendship,
in the future.
I served you faithfully for
thirty-two years,
and Mandy twenty years.
At $25.00 a month for me,
and $2.00 a week for Mandy,
our earnings would amount to
$11,680.00.
Add to this the interest for
the time our wages has been kept
back, and deduct what you paid
for our clothing and three
doctors' visits for me and
pulling a tooth for Mandy,
and the balance will show what
we are in justice entitled to.
Please send the money,
by Adam's Express,
care of V.
Winters Esquire,
Dayton, Ohio."
He goes on another paragraph,
and then there's a P.S.
"Say howdy to George Carter,
and thank him for taking the
pistol from you when you were
shooting at me."
What did freedom mean?
What had the war meant?
Wages, with interest,
according to Jordan Anderson.
Well, we'll see whether the
United States would help out old
Jordan.
All right, now Reconstruction
is, of course,
that ten or eleven year period
of American history that
sometimes,
too often--I don't know how it
was taught to you-- but
sometimes, too often we skirt
through.
It's complicated,
not as much glory to go around
as there is during the war.
It's fraught with some
skullduggery and corruption on
an unprecedented scale,
on all kinds of sides.
It's a time of enormous
imagination and experimentation,
in politics and law.
It's also the time in American
history when we have by far our
largest level of domestic
terrorism and violence--a good
deal more on that in the weeks
to come.
But Reconstruction policy,
of course, began during the
war.
The debates over Reconstruction
policy began during the war.
Well sorry, I had Herman
Melville's poem here but what
did I do with Herman Melville?
Forgive me.
"Check that," as the old sports
announcer used to say.
The policies on Reconstruction
took two paths,
and those paths begin as early
as late 1863,
and they are especially being
debated in the federal
government in 1864,
and they are ripe by the end of
the war in 1865.
Lincoln's basic approach to
Reconstruction,
when and if they could end the
war,
win the war and stop it,
was to make Reconstruction as
fast as possible,
as lenient as
possible--remember these three
things,
you're going to hear it
again--as fast as possible,
as lenient as possible,
and as much as possible under
presidential authority,
not Congress.
He's going to fashion this
so-called Ten Percent Plan,
which I'll explain next time,
but it in essence meant that he
wanted ten percent of the white
voting population of a former
Confederate state to take a
loyalty oath to the Union,
to redraw a new constitution,
denounce secession,
accept emancipation,
and they would be readmitted to
the Union under presidential
authority.
And he wanted to do as much of
it as possible during the war
because when the war ends he
could lose his presidential war
powers.
In Congress,
in his own party,
led by Thaddeus Stevens in the
House and Charles Sumner in the
Senate--and you'll learn a good
deal more about that in the two
weeks to come--there's a very
different approach to
Reconstruction.
The Congressional Radicals,
as they become known,
Republicans all,
want a Reconstruction that is
longer, harsher,
and under Congressional
control.
Now Lincoln won't be around,
of course, to engage in this
battle after the war is over,
but he was there during the
war, and they had quite a tussle
over imagining how
Reconstruction would happen.
Now if you want to get a sense
of Lincoln's approach to
Reconstruction,
now you can read the last
paragraph of the Second
Inaugural about malice toward
none and charity for all and
binding up the nation's wound,
and so forth.
But there's also the statement
he made in his last cabinet
meeting, the last meeting he had
of his cabinet,
before he went to Ford's
Theater, literally that night.
He said to his cabinet,
and I'm quoting:
"I hope that there will be no
persecutions,
no bloody work after the war is
over.
No one need expect me to take
any part in hanging or killing
these men, even the worst of
them.
Frighten them out of the
country, open the gates,
let down the bars,
scare them off,
but enough lives have been
sacrificed."
That's one approach,
but that is not the approach of
the leaders of the Congressional
Republicans,
some of whom would've wished
for there to be some treason
trials and executions,
but short of that they want a
Reconstruction that's going to
reshape the American polity,
rewrite the U.S.
Constitution,
and remake Southern society.
Anyone I ever run into who says
"Reconstruction's too
complicated and not
interesting,"
I don't understand it,
because how can you have that
kind of thing happening and it
not be interesting?
But I found Melville, sorry.
Let me leave you with this.
Spare the poets.
Melville wrote this little
poem, after Lincoln was
murdered.
Listen to what he says.
"Good Friday was the day Of the
prodigy and crime,
When they killed him in his
pity,
prime Of clemency and calm--When
with yearning he was filled To
redeem the evil-willed,
And, though conqueror, be kind;
But they killed him in his
kindness, In their madness and
their blindness,
And they killed him from
behind.
There is sobbing of the strong,
And a pall upon the land;
But the People in their weeping
Bare an iron hand;
Beware the People weeping When
they bare the iron hand.
He lieth in his blood--the
father in his face;
They have killed him,
the Forgiver--The Avenger now
takes his place,
The Avenger wisely stern,
Who in righteousness shall do
What the heavens call him to,
And the parricides remand;
For they killed him in his
kindness, In their madness and
their blindness,
And his blood is on their hand.
There is sobbing of the strong,
And a pall upon the land;
But the People in their weeping
Bare the iron hand;
Beware the People weeping When
they bare an iron hand."
The whole history of
Reconstruction has always been a
debate really over how iron the
hand should've been.
Thank you, see you next week.